great all right good morning so what
makes something revolutionary for
purposes of this talk I'm gonna propose
the following definition something is
revolutionary when it not only totally
disrupts the established order but it
replaces the established order with a
new order and thus it changes the
dynamics of everything around it the
discipline of front-end development is
continuing to change at a meteoric rate
and in hindsight this isn't actually a
big surprise for ours is the discipline
that deals with the user people and how
they interact in their emotions and so
of course we're going to need more of us
as more and more people continue to get
on the internet and as our devices have
taken over and things are chaotic every
day we have a new tool new frameworks
sometimes it's absolutely exhausting to
keep up and in fact all of these new
tools are transforming our lives as
developers and designers they're giving
us these new capabilities that we can
turn into new opportunities and this is
actually what's important over the last
few years we've had to adopt to many
many many many many new changes and it's
these behavioral changes that we make to
keep up with our craft that's actually
revolutionary and that's because
revolutions don't happen when we adopt
new technologies
they actually happen when we adopt new
behaviors so what are these behaviors
that we've actually adopted right and
how do we go about understanding what a
behavior is so before we get into that
we're going to look at the doctor frog's
behavior method which is a model for
persuasive technology for developing
persuasive technology and dr. Fogg leads
the persuasive tech lab at Stanford
University and in the 90s his big thing
was that he published a paper that said
you know what computers might actually
be able to alter and change what we do
and I was kind of mind-blowing for
people so what is his model his model
states that behavior is actually
composed of three factors its motivation
ability and a trigger and all three of
these things need to be present in order
for us to do anything so first we need
to be sufficiently motivated and
motivation is really anything that gets
you to act for some you might be
motivated by money for others they might
be motivated by freedom and so given
that motivation is so subjective it's
actually not a good thing to rely just
on motivation to change someone's
behavior second is ability and the
ability is a bit of a difficult one to
explain it really has to deal with how
simple or easy something is and that
varies individually for a person for
example if a task at hand is going to
take ten minutes and you don't have ten
minutes then you aren't able to perform
that task even if that task is
relatively easy for you it isn't so
persuasive technologies really focus on
lowering ability lowering that barrier
to entry no matter what so that it's
easy for anyone to get into it unless
Lea triggers
which can be squirrels for some people
depending who you are they can take many
forms so a trigger can be anything such
as like an alarm or a notification a an
article that you've read that's
prompting you to do something and there
are three characteristics two triggers
that make them successful first we
actually have to notice them second we
have to associate this trigger with a
target behavior and third when it
actually happens we have to be
sufficiently motivated to perform the
behavior so it looks like this on a
graph basically if this line is behavior
anything that happens here will result
in a successful behavior and anything
that occurs in here will result in an in
successful behavior so you can see that
the easier something is to do with lower
motivation now you're gonna capped it
cap get more people but the harder it
gets some more motivation you also need
to require make sure that it's easy to
do if something requires a high level of
motivation and it's hard to do very few
people are actually going to be able to
do it so you keep this in mind when we
start to take a look at how our tools
use this persuasive technology model to
get us to use them and adopt their
behaviors so now we need to back up a
little bit to the mid arts to take a
look at how behavior how our tools
utilize this model to to affect our
behavior and because we're talking about
front-end we don't actually have to go
all the way back in time about 2005 is
2007 and there was a lot of sort of
rumblings happen in web development
we're coming out of the web standards
movement in 2000 javascript and CSS at
this point in time are really poised for
some change
it's kind of difficult to navigate the
web so there was a bunch of new
JavaScript frameworks and they were all
aimed at addressing the API
inconsistencies that we were
experiencing as web developers and in
2006 john resonating released jQuery and
it wasn't the first framework that came
out we can see that they were actually a
bunch of them but jQuery did three
things that none of these other tools
managed to do in time first had a really
really simple solution to Dom
manipulation second it released with
really good documentation there were
libraries that came out before for
example of the prototype library that
was adopted in rails it didn't have
documentation for the first year or so
that makes it really hard for anyone to
jump in and figure out what to do and
lastly when jQuery launched it launched
with an invitation for people to
participate and to contribute and by the
second day someone had already released
the first plug-in and this was amazing
this was the first time that you could
do this and John's response is to say
you know what I'm gonna make this a
really big thing I'm gonna ensure that
we have a place for anyone to contribute
their code and that it's easy for them
to do it because he realized the value
of what was going on so J's jQuery
success is the fact that it took a very
simple approach which allowed anyone to
join even if you had sufficient
motivation and at that time period we
can say that our motivation was
incredibly high it was a nightmare to be
working on the web
secondly good documentation making
making it easy the ability lowering the
ability and this invitation to
participate
perhaps a trigger and perhaps the other
triggers were just the articles that
were coming out now it's still the
number one open source framework in use
and there's been a lot of grumbling
whether or not we should continue using
jQuery I'm not going to go into that in
this confidence thing in this talk I
leave that up to you to decide but the
really important thing is that these
three design decisions paved the way for
big revolution in front-end development
and it led to other projects like node
and react and all the amazing things
that are coming out in JavaScript now
which is why we have these week-long
conferences all over the world so
contribution has always been a major
part of back-end development it's kind
of a big tenant of the web right but its
foray into front-end development is very
very recent and in CSS since sort of the
UX world this is even more recent so
around the same time that jQuery is kind
of picking up speed CSS on the other
hand is really ready for its Renaissance
let's take a look at where we were about
mid odds somehow we had decided that 960
pixels was the best way to design our
websites and the only way to design our
websites we also had ie6 7 8 9 who knows
how many other browsers and we were
finally really excited for this thing
called css3 that was going to help rid
our HTML of a bunch of tag soup but what
did that introduce a bunch of vendor
prefixes because all the browser's
couldn't decide how
they wanted to adopt it and who had to
deal with that pain we did right so it's
not surprising that we wanted new things
and additionally here comes the
smartphone completely about to change
every notion that we have a best
practice and we start developing these
new techniques for dealing with things
like smacks and object-oriented CSS and
BEM and conventions that are trying to
save our life and so it's really no
surprise that preprocessors arrived and
much like jQuery and JavaScript there
were a ton I didn't know about these but
I CSS P P DT CSS a bunch of free
processors because our need was was
evident but there were two that really
edged out and how did that happen
the reason is by the same design
decisions so SAS was always kind of
touted as one of the more powerful ones
but it had a really big contender less
and less adoption and Jake in excuse me
in boot shop is one of the reasons that
I think it continued and once SAS picked
up the CSS syntax it made it much easier
for anyone to come in and to collaborate
so we can see that we had the motivation
but SAS was a little more difficult to
use but it did edge out and last year it
won the game changer award and recently
there was an article published that said
that a 66% a front end people are using
SAS today which is huge but it took some
other things
well SAS
was sort of answering our problems for
dealing with vendor prefixes and making
it easier to write CSS I feel that it
wasn't until compass came along and
provided a way for authoring writers
ourselves to contribute and it was a
little complicated
we grumbled at first we had to learn
Ruby and how to make ruby gems but it
ultimately paid off and now it's even
easier to contribute this things like
libsass where you don't even have to
worry about packaging up and creating
ruby gems anymore as long as you build
an extensible framework your sass file
can be included and used anywhere and
it's amazing right we now have an
amazing amount of tools people are
creating new things every day we're
experimenting and this was this is new
we couldn't do this before we were
writing blog posts and trying to share
tips and tricks but we couldn't share
our code and aside from joining the
working group there was no way to really
affect change in the language and what's
even more incredible is how these tools
are now influencing the parent language
and there's a bunch of amazing new
things coming out in CSS level 4
we've got variables in CSS where did
that come from
that came from sass that came from
pre-processors we have mix-ins
we have grids we have blend modes there
are so many amazing things and yes I
don't necessarily have full insight into
the working group so I'm sure that they
are developing ideas on their own but
I'm also positive that they're looking
at the changes in the community to make
those decisions you can also see that
with
recent release of epimer script six and
how it took a lot of its new features
from CoffeeScript why did CoffeeScript
come out because we were tired of
writing a lot of j/s and there was a lot
of inconsistencies that CoffeeScript
nicely packaged away for us so we could
do things the right way and this is
incredible our tools are lowering the
threshold for finding new ideas and by
doing this they've opened up tremendous
opportunity for finding for for new
things we're free to experiment we can
get out there we don't have to rely on
these larger institutions and this is
very new this is this participatory
innovation that we're talking about our
tools have created a participatory
culture and our traditional rules don't
really matter anymore because we can
move ahead of them and this is
incredibly important because it's the
ability for collective participation and
collective action that are really the
necessary ingredients for change our
tools have enabled us to try radical
things we're creating environments in
which people can get things done and
we're doing this while being encouraging
and supportive and welcoming so it was
really fascinating for me is when you
start to look at the growth of our tools
in the adoption and you can do this in
Google Trends we get this really
interesting distribution which tends to
look like a power log and in network
science this type of graph of behavior
represents a small world network and
small world networks our networks that
are built up of many nodes that are
connected to each other and they have to
incredibly evolutionary advance
advantages the first is that they're
resistant to damage and the second is
that they disseminate information really
well they act both as filters and
amplifiers so what's incredible is that
perhaps without us even really noticing
it we've designed our front-end
communities for growth and resilience
and so given that we are so skilled at
creating such a resilient Network one
that values the uniqueness of its
members and the people within it and
given that we can do so in such a short
amount of time
oonh really is a decade ten years I
really believe that we have a lot to
contribute back to society
beyond just great websites and
experiences citizens the world over are
already calling for change and I believe
along with many others that in order for
this change to happen it's only going to
come through a participatory revolution
and I also predict that we're gonna see
a very big change from solving technical
problems to more interpersonal problems
about the people and who better to take
part in this than us we are successful
practicing models of participatory
culture it's not we may take this for
granted but it's really incredible not
everyone works this way not everyone has
the ability to work this way and so
maybe we can put the same design
decisions that we've put into our tools
into making cities better into improving
education systems
code literacy holds immense power it's
more than just a job or a career change
it's this ability to participate in the
largest human connected network that's
what the web is it has a culture it has
a history it has a social structure and
it's shaped by each of us so it's really
up to us to decide where we want to
create these opportunities and what we
want to do with them and it'll vary by
what we can do it can be as large as
organizing this conference and bring us
together to talk and share it can be as
small as taking the time to mentor
someone and help them write a blog post
release the plug-in it doesn't matter
what it is what matters most right now
is that we keep creating because this is
what's going to determine what comes
next and there's less harm in that so
please make up and while we do it
just remember to continue to be
inclusive and welcoming because if we do
this if we will continue to innovate and
given what we've just observed I really
believe that our innovations will
continue to be revolutionary thank you
so much